I've made my first million dollars in a
year setting up construction sites and I
had this homeowner Bethany and Bethany
calls me up she goes hey you have a
great reputation I see you flipping all
these houses for these other investors
come flip a house for me so we go crush
it for do a second house done she calls
me for a third house and she comes up
behind me and she goes get out of your
truck right now and I'm like what did I
do and she was like why aren't you in
real estate and I go I am in real estate
then she says something that really
shocked me she said you're not in real
estate you're a service provider to me
and I'm in real estate you are a simple
Google search away from being replaced
you're as replaceable as the mortgage
company you're as replaceable as my
private money lender I'm gonna ask you
again why are you not in real estate she
says I want you to send out a swath of
postcards and I get my first deal two
weeks later and I was like this took me
three hours of work to do this why am I
a freaking contractor